la législation de l'avortement sera
cette nuit entre les mains du sénat
argentin
une loi approuvée par l'assemblée le 11
décembre dernier mais dont le sort reste
encore un certain temps les voies entre
les pour et les contre sont partagés au
sein de la chambre haute un dossier
épineux que le président alberto
fernandez lors de sa campagne avait
promis de soumettre aux parlementaires
je suis catholique mais je doit
légiférer pour tous
c'est un sujet de santé publique très
sérieux dans la ruche depuis un mois les
manifestations s'enchaînent
hier ils étaient plusieurs milliers à
buenos aires pour marcher contre
l'avortement
de nombreux catholiques faisait partie
du cortège même si d'autres estiment que
leur présence n'est pas une question de
religion
il ne faut pas confondre ce n'est pas
une question de religion d'ailleurs moi
je suis athée cela n'a rien à voir avec
la religion même si beaucoup sont
effectivement catholiques évangéliques
il apporte des vierges des croix cela
n'a rien à voir c'est une question
scientifique de reconnaître que la vie
commence dès la conception et morale
d'accepter et de reconnaître qu'il est
mal de tuer une personne que ce soit
avant ou après sa naissance
ils vont voter contre la femme contre la
famille et contre l'avis de leur côté
les pro avortement se sont mobilisés eux
aussi notamment le 11 décembre dernier
pour acclamer la décision des députés
aujourd'hui les deux camps ont prévu
d'être présents devant le parlement
la question semble donc divisé le pays
selon le gouvernement entre 370 milles
et 520 milles avortements clandestins
ont lieu chaque année en argentine
aujourd'hui elles seules les femmes
ayant subi un viol ou dont la vie est
menacée par des complications lors de
leur grossesse sont autorisés à apporter
selon une loi datant de 1921